we're going to take you now to a crisis
developing a small town in Arizona that
just lost its only reliable source of
water more than one thousand residents
of Rio Verdi Foothills had gotten their
water from the nearby city of Scottsdale
but that supply has now been cut off
Scottsdale says it cannot spare any more
water because of the historic drought in
the west Chris Van Cleave shows how
people are struggling to find a solution
there
in Rio Verde Foothills people paid to
haul water from the city of Scottsdale
into their Community for more than 30
years but now we're just using our
buckets from the garage right now and
collecting the rain water folks like
Karen nabity are desperately searching
for Alternatives I'm using rain water in
here to even wash my hands with to rinse
dishes with for flushing the toilets
while Rio Verde neighbors Scottsdale it
is an unincorporated community so it's
not connected to the city's water
utility and its residents do not figure
into the population count for the city's
water supply so starting January 1st
Scottsdale stopped allowing its water to
be transported Beyond City Limits
turning off the spigot to re-overt a
Foothills my community is beautiful it's
the most special place in Arizona
and if it doesn't have water for the
people that live there it's going to die
last week Rio Verde residents packed
Scottsdale city council meeting to
protest the new water restriction dozens
also filed a lawsuit against the city
arguing the policy would cause immediate
and irreparable harm and asking the
court for a permanent stay against the
move it really was not reasonable for
them to expect that they had a forever
Supply Scottsdale is going to look like
the big mean City that's cutting these
people off from water but they have
their own citizens who need that water
as well exactly water policy expert
Sarah Porter tells CBS mornings Rio
Verde residents will likely have to turn
to other costlier water sources or build
infrastructure of their own one
potential provider canadian-based
utility epcor has said it's willing to
help but it'll need at least two years
to get up and running Porter called the
situation A cautionary tale even though
there won't be a lot of new algorithms
it is a signal that cities are paying
more attention to how they take care of
the water supplies that they have in
there a sentiment echoed by Scottsdale
mayor David Ortega who spoke with Brook
silver Braga for CBS Saturday morning
last November why not just let those few
people keep the water for a little
longer they should manage their own
destiny with their own water yeah we
have to adapt and then we have to adapt
more and we have to adapt more for CBS
mornings I'm Chris Van Cleave